hey guys pete here today i'm going to do
a detailed breakdown of the new expanse
season 5
trailer it just came out it's loaded
with interesting stuff
and looks absolutely amazing we also got
a season 5 release date of december 16th
and found out that they'll be dropping
the new episodes like they did with the
boys new season
that means the first three episodes will
air on the 16th
then after that the rest of the episodes
will drop weekly
when i made my season 4 video i asked
viewers what they thought about the
binge release
so i know opinions are mixed but i'm
super excited about this
i like the discussions in between
episodes when you have a weekly release
and i'll definitely be doing weekly
videos for what i
think will turn out to be the best
season of the expanse yet
in this video i'm going to take a deep
dive look at everything we saw in the
first
trailer i've read all the expanse books
so i have a good idea of where things
are going but i won't go into book
spoilers in this video
if you aren't caught up with the tv show
of the expanse through the fourth season
then this video won't be for you also
i'll add that there is a lot in this
trailer so i'm not gonna shy away from
putting together pieces that we can from
previous seasons
you might learn some things about what's
gonna happen in this if you decide to
leave hit the subscribe button on the
way out though
because i will be making videos to recap
and discuss each episode and have some
other ones planned
to put out between now and the beginning
of the season with all that out of the
way let's get into it
the trailer opens with marco
broadcasting on the news feeds
he says my name is marco inaros i am the
commander of the free
navy with the opening of the alien gates
we're at the crossroads
no longer will belters be persecuted
with this attack we will show our
oppressors the strength they never
thought
possible the future of the belt has
begun
this picks up from where things left off
in the fourth season
and it sets the tone for how the
beginning of this season's going to go
down we see that his broadcast is
spreading out and
that people are seeing it throughout the
system in that we see
our first look of characters we see
naomi and then holden
we see christian avasarala watching the
feed drummer in a ship
looking like she found out about ashford
at this point
amos by himself and then alex and bobby
in a ship together which i'll come back
to
later so there's a ton of cool shots cut
in
throughout this thing in the beginning
we see an overhead shot of luna
and one of the ring gates where we see a
lot of ships in transit
we also see the asteroids that marco was
sending to earth for whatever he was
planning at the end of season four
from here on out i'm going to refer to
those as the rocks
his group the free navy has applied
stealth tech to those and threw them
towards earth they have to
cover a great distance to get there so
we get an idea what the rossi crew will
be getting
up to now that they have finished up on
ellis and pass
through the ring gate back into saul's
system we get a scene with holden and
fred johnson on tycho station
fred tells him to be grateful for the
things he has
his own ship a great crew people that he
loves
and that he's not responsible for the
world now that miller's gone from his
head
holden seems to be struggling with what
his purpose is
then we see a transport ship landing on
luna and learn from avasarala that amos
is going back to earth it's nice to see
these two in a room together and when
she asked him why he's going he just
says i have personal business in
baltimore
in the next scene we see him on the
ground to know that he made it
later we see him meet someone at an
apartment who says
i was always waiting for you to turn up
the takeaway here is that we'll be
learning about
amos's life before he left earth and
some of how he came to be who he is
we also get some shots of him traveling
through deserted areas on the surface
they only show us long shots so you
can't see what's going on but he's with
someone else
since they seem to want to keep this
character's identity secret i won't say
who it is
but book readers know we also see him in
a fight with a couple of guys where his
opponent
lunges at him with a knife based on the
books i think this is something that
happens in the ship on the way back to
earth in the voice over amos says
this world is messed up float to the top
or sink to the bottom
everything in the middle is a churn
that's a reference
to the novella that's based on amos's
origin story more or less
his time growing up on earth before he
left and the circumstances under which
that happened
it's super exciting that we get to learn
some of those details because it
certainly helps to understand the
character
and why he does some of the things he
does there's another interesting shot
of him holding a rifle with some new
characters that looks like it also takes
place on earth
as you can see this is a solo mission
for him the crew of the rossi will be
splitting up
going in different directions this
season we know naomi ended last season
reaching out to fred johnson
calling in her favor asking him to find
her son
phillip in the trailer we see him giving
her that information on tycho
later she tells holden she's chartered a
freighter for palace station which tells
us that she's going to find him we see
her
arriving there we see philip it looks
like he's there
and even see a flashback shot of her and
marcos when philip was a baby
for the rest of holden scenes in the
trailer we see that he's not with the
normal rossi crew
with naomi off looking for her son and
amos going back to earth for his
personal business
it looks like alex goes back to his home
plan and it looks like he heads back to
mars
we see him with bobby who was there the
last time we saw her
and we get the idea that she's looking
into the mars connection
of the marco situation that ashford was
trying to figure out before his death we
get a shot of bobby and alex together
here where she has a display of her
investigation up we can't see all the
details of who's involved but we can see
the crooked cop
aside connected to the martian bobby was
suspicious of in the last job they did
where those two were both
killed we see that he's connected to
philip who was on mars picking up the
stealth
tech and how she's put connections to
unnamed characters on the martian side
one of which is wearing a military
uniform in the voice over she says
i don't know if it's a single huge
conspiracy but someone high up in the
chain of command
is in on it so she has suspicions that
someone high in the martian military
was involved with what happened at the
end of season four
when the belters got away with the
stealth technology
then we see another shot of bobby and
alex on the ship and when we get a look
at it we see that it's julie mal's ship
the razorback which we haven't seen
since season three
so it's exciting that we'll get to see
that again and bobby and alex working
together
pulling her back into the fold where she
was away from
everyone in season four on the belter
side of things we see that drummer will
continue to play a big role in season
five
we see her finding ashford's ship and
then later we see her face to face with
marco where she says
you have committed the entire belt to
war with the inners
it seems likely that she's looking for
revenge for ashford but it's not clear
what the details behind this meeting are
it looks like they're on marco's ship
and that we'll be visiting there
often like we'll spend time there it's
good to see that she's still
involved since cara g does a great job
and people are familiar with her
her role has been a combination of
characters from the books which means i
think i know where she'll fit in but i
don't spot anything
in the trailer that spells it out there
are several shots of both marco and
philip and what we can imagine is the
time while the rocks are headed towards
earth
there's even one shot where we can see
the two of them together with naomi
standing in front of them
this would confirm that she was able to
find philip but it's not clear from this
or any other shots in the trailer what
she'll do when that happens
other than that she's alone in the shots
that we see
obviously the big cliffhanger from last
season is what marco's
plan actually is and whether or not
he'll be able to pull it off
in the trailer we get the idea that
there'll be time for a lot to transpire
from when he launched the rocks until
when they arrive
in this shot we see that it says time to
impact 12 days
7 hours 13 minutes with the coordinates
being off the coast of africa
if i had to guess the rock story will
likely reach its conclusion around the
end of the third
episode considering how much happens
after that
there's a scene of christian talking to
nancy gal
and military commanders on earth from
luna saying i have information that
inaros intends to attack civilian
targets with the shot of earth and then
this shot of someone on a beach
watching something stream across the sky
a little later
we hear her tell a commander marco has
millions of belters
if we go toe-to-toe with him we could
lose most of the shots we see her
in look like she stays on luna aka the
moon
which in the expanse's timeline has
about 1 billion people on it it's the
point between
earth and system travel which is why she
ran into amos on his way down to the
planet
as mentioned holden is the only member
of the rossi crew who stayed put in the
belt at tycho
there's an out-of-context shot of him
grabbing a gun that was floating next to
someone who was recently
shot and then later we see him with a
couple of new characters saying
it's time to take the rossi out for a
hunt like i said most of that is without
context other than you know he's split
up from everyone and he's out pretty far
away from
the earth where the rocks are headed the
final bit of voice over is a belter
saying marco's going to accomplish what
a century of leaders have promised he's
going to unite
a hundred separate factions into one
nation that's followed with marcos
saying it's time to let the system know
who we are as that's going we get
several shots of belters who look united
with shots of marco and philip together
and philip on his own and a close-up
shot of naomi by herself
those are cut with shots above sarla and
her people on luna which look like
they're waiting to see what will happen
and if the attack will be successful so
a lot of crazy stuff there to get us
hyped up
some other interesting shots that were
mixed in there the character that greets
amos in baltimore
is an actor you might recognize if you
watch the wire
which is kind of funny since that show
took place in baltimore as well
this fred johnson scene is really
intriguing he's surrounded by this
effect that looks similar to what lv
okoye saw
when she helped miller turn off the
proto-molecule on ellis
passing through what he called the
bullet this isn't something that's
directly taken from the book so i'm
really curious as to what's going on
here
i mean i have an idea but can't wait to
find out
there's a shot of the mrc with the map
of the ring gates we see a bunch of
people sitting around
kind of this big floating graphic it's a
visually interesting
shot but can't say for sure what's
happening here
at the end of season 4 we saw how the
ring gate's opening will more or less be
the end
for mars with so many habitable worlds
on the other side of them
why continue a terraforming project that
will take
generations to accomplish remember
avasarala lost the election
and nancy gao was basically campaigning
on
colonizing all the worlds beyond the
rings
so the whole power struggle is going to
shift and we can see from the trailer
that marco's trying to position the belt
in a place of power with the free navy
there are several shots of the rocks we
see what looks like them breaking up
at different points and perhaps entering
atmosphere what happens with them is the
big mystery of the first part of the
season
so one thing i thought stood out from
the trailer is how
exciting that's going to kind of be with
that ticking clock situation
and all these other characters moving
around because obviously the characters
don't really know what's happening but
as viewers we will so that'll be a lot
of fun to watch
i don't know about you but i can't wait
until december 16th
let me know in the comments what you
think about the season 5 trailer and
what you're most excited about
if you've read the books that's awesome
but don't be a jerk and give the story
away
you know i'm a huge fan of the books and
the show i'd be glad to discuss book
stuff but just mark the comments with
spoilers so that you don't ruin anything
for anyone else
i'm gonna leave it there let's pick it
up in the comments
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
as i mentioned i'll be doing a ton of
expanse videos between now
and the end of this season if you
thought season four was a little bit of
a drag compared to the first three
i would say definitely stick in there
this is going to be
a much different season and a lot of
stuff's going to happen
nothing's going to be the same so thanks
for watching and i'll talk to you soon